hey yeah you got a 10-incher they're not
worrying about your balls
ka-flump ew no balls
fellas ryan long back to answer the
internet would you rather have sex with
two midgets or two seven foot tall girls
one of each is not an option
unfortunately
i think that you want to go
i mean depends like obviously if the two
midgets is like pretty cool thing to do
but the tall girls you might be that
might be more of a regular thing but
seven foot tall yeah i'm a sort of a
tall guy but i've never i don't think
i've slept with a girl that's taller
than me how tall are you 6'3 so imagine
someone nine inches tall why be suspect
that they aren't girls for starters you
know i mean it's a two seven [ __ ]
two seven footers come in and they're
like no we're chicks for real though i
don't i got these they don't got a great
[ __ ]
sounds a little like 2022 chicks if you
ask me
would you rather have two normal kids or
a disabled kid and one nf and one kid in
the nfl i'd rather have two disabled
i have kids disabled kids
and one kid in the wnfl so it's one
disabled kid and one kid in the nfl so a
woman and a kid in the nfl
if you could see a sex tape with any two
movie characters
who would it be
let's say newman and kramer from
seinfeld
yeah yeah and i would also like jerry to
walk in and he goes
hello jerry
would you rather be magic johnson with
aids or a regular dude
um this is people helping you right the
south bark thing all right well magic
johnson is potentially doesn't have aids
there is this sort of a conspiracy going
around that he doesn't have eggs he was
just doing it for sympathy
they typically conspiracy that's going
around my house since i started saying
it
we used it
there was a guy that we knew and uh he
was named margereck marjorick we used to
call him margie johnson
fun stuff
is jerking off to webcam girls cheating
no next
it bet it [ __ ] better not be
but jerking off the webcam guys
is even less so have you ever done a
live chat thing no but i had a well i
had my pimp set me up for a bunch of
them but i got called
the uh i had a couple of girls like
maybe this is like a couple years ago
girl being like hey i'm a webcam girl
and i'm like a big fan can i give you a
free webcam session i was kind of like
yeah that sounds pretty sick but i've
never done that before so like doesn't
this seem weird like i don't know you're
like hey okay i'll go big fan anyway
like start and then she's like
i don't know what and then what and then
you pulling your dick out you're just
just
you're at the other end of the zoom like
no
well done
seems weird right yeah there you go
i don't know anybody i mean we're all
we're disgusting perverts i know a ton
of degenerates i don't know anybody who
does the webcam you know what's so funny
they still do i watched comedy central
when i was on the road and they have the
commercials are all like call this
number yeah can you imagine still
that is crazy
on your [ __ ] land line like and then
what are you doing you know crazy
i probably it gets problematic once you
start like having like relationships
with them where you're just like
you're that they love me guy would you
rather take four million dollars to be
caught on to catch a predator
well that would be i buy a lot of pizza
right but
do you remember that guy
no because if you could what do what's
four million you didn't do it like
you're not gonna go to jail before
there's a mix-up whatever what time is
there how many times has there been a
mix you watch this show there's rarely a
mix-up
you watch this you're on their side the
guy's like dude i thought she was 15.
he's like oh well there you go okay next
i mean i
i jumped to conclusions there's the one
guy he got caught and he sat there
eating his pizza and he was like yeah
can i eat my pizza bro like he played it
cool well the other thing is it's worth
the you know it's worth that to meet my
hero chris hanson so it's maybe a big
that'll be a treat for me for sure mr
hansen was into some weird [ __ ]
afterwards and yeah he started like he
tried to pivot from like the catching
pedophiles guy to standard you know
calling people racist and stuff guy and
it wasn't having the same buzz you know
he's like yeah remember that guy that i
took down for being a pedophile went and
threw some twitter accounts and uh
a little bit of a derogatory slur for
the italians we got the attack get out
of here [ __ ] off chris hanson mary [ __ ]
kill gushers fruit by the foot snake
bites this is so obvious though that you
[ __ ] gushers
um obviously
i assume they're novelty size large
gushers
shark bites what's a shark bite no you
kill shark bites and you marry fruit by
the foot how much money would it take
for you to not drink for a year that's a
pretty that's a pretty good question
like in current scenario where it's like
okay this is just gonna be like a pain
in the ass you're doing for nothing i
would say
maybe 100k it's like gonna be such a
pain in the ass
and i don't have like a drinking problem
where i got to be the guy that's like
this is even from any positives it's all
it is it's like uncomfortable every
night i gotta be like no i'm doing this
bet and okay well then we'll stop
inviting you next time
who is the worst group of fans best
group of fans is juggalos worst group of
fans will smith fans
they're yelling at me recently i did a
video making fun of will smith because
his like wife keeps cheating on him or
whatever and it was more just like that
they keep putting it out there right and
then will smith fans were coming at me
like dude this is too far like you you
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] i've done too is
like will smith you [ __ ] make fun of
a man's wife
they keep you go what are they up to
every day they go on first of all they
have this show together as a family and
every time they go on and she was like
you know we had some problems because
will smith has not been able to pleasure
me sexually and this is a topic for this
evening and will's like yes very bad and
he's like why is he doing this
it's like i think he likes to i think
it's like he's being cucked
he enjoys it
could you beat tom cruise in a fight i
don't think anyone could beat tom cruise
in a fight you think you could [ __ ] up
tom cruise dude that's like my brother's
always like like he's like ufc fighters
one class under them he goes it'd be
easy man it'd be like [ __ ] candy from
a baby
tom cruise though well he's old now
he runs though he runs like i think 80
miles of movie
wahlberg dude wahlberg and cruz if you
ever watch when they're on like late
night shows their feet don't touch the
ground
it's [ __ ] crazy i'm sure they're
tough guys oh that's the whole thing
they've got a lot to prove tom cruise is
always doing his own stunt no matter
what it was it's like
he's getting to the point where it's
like no i actually got shot for that
movie it's like not necessary
no no no no one has to get shot he's
like we're making [ __ ] film here
would you rather have a 10 inch dick
with no balls
a four-inch dick with balls what happens
if you already have a 10-inch dick no
balls do so they get rid of the one you
already do
i mean this is a pretty obvious one
imagine this is one of those ones that
you'd really have buyers regret if you
went for the balls in the four inches
the girl being like dude your [ __ ]
dick's pretty small and you're like it's
a long story
hey yeah you got a 10-incher they're not
worrying about your balls
ew no balls
would you rather be falsely accused of
murder
or never be able to stop coming well if
i get falsely accused of murder and go
to jail i'll never be able to stop
coming
so either way
either way we're gonna be [ __ ] coming
put me around all those hot prisoners
especially once i go trans and go to the
girls prison
hello i mean never be able to stop
coming is probably a fate worse than
anything
no you can't do anything hey how's it
going
you have to be you have to keep yourself
well nourished too i think there wasn't
wasn't that the old thing whereas like a
guy came 30 times and he died and then
that was the old that was the old wives
tale that i was going around my house
anyway
i was told it was due
thing is like that guy he jerked off so
many times that he died really yeah
well he just yeah he died he goes well
we did it
yeah he reached he reached the pinnacle
shout out to the boy ryan long make sure
you check him out and make sure you
check us out by subscribing clicking
notifications and leaving a comment
below on answer the internet